ahora que ya sabemos que la tasa de
interés es esencialmente el precio de
que te rente en el dinero me gustaría
ver contigo un montón de escenarios en
estos escenarios yo lo que quiero ver es
ver los efectos que tienen las tasas de
interés en algunas cosas económicas por
lo tanto vamos a hablar bastante en esta
ocasión acerca de la curva de la demanda
y la curva de la oferta del dinero y
bueno no lo olvides realmente lo que
estamos hablando es acerca del mercado
de bueno esencialmente de la renta del
dinero en el eje vertical tenemos el
precio del dinero es decir la tasa del
interés la tasa de interés mientras que
en el eje horizontal tenemos la cantidad
es decir cuánta cantidad de dinero te
van a prestar entonces aquí está la
cantidad la cantidad del dinero que te
van a prestar en un periodo de tiempo
dado entonces vamos a suponer que es la
cantidad que te prestan en un año
y bueno si recordamos un poco acerca de
lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado
hablábamos de cuando tenemos la curva de
la demanda empieza por aquí porque
cuando a nosotros nos prestan una
cantidad de dinero pequeña entonces las
tasas de interés son muy altas
mientras que si nosotros aumentamos peso
a peso nuestra deuda entonces las tasas
de interés van a ir disminuyendo porque
el beneficio marginal va a ir
disminuyendo o lo podemos pensar de la
siguiente manera entre más tasa de
interés exista pues entonces menos
dinero se va a prestar la gente no va a
querer sacar préstamos mientras que
entre más bajas en la tasa de interés
pues entonces más gente va a querer
sacar dinero y por lo tanto los
préstamos van a ser más grandes y más
dinero se va a prestar por lo tanto la
curva de la demanda se ve con una curva
decreciente más o menos como ésta y en
general es la misma lógica que estoy
usando para dibujar estas gráficas que
cualquier otra gráfica de la curva de la
demanda o la curva de la oferta pasa
exactamente lo mismo y bueno esto me da
pie va a decir que la curva de la oferta
se va a ver más o menos así y ya con
esto tenemos aquí nuestro punto de
equilibrio acerca del precio y la
cantidad de dinero que te van a prestar
así que déjenme copiar y pegar toda esta
gráfica porque la voy a ocupar de nuevo
exactamente la misma pero le vamos a
hacer modificaciones vamos a pensar qué
es lo que pasa en diferentes escenarios
y voy a copiar y pegar 2
porque quiero ver dos escenarios
actualmente contigo bueno ahora lo que
quiero ver en el primer escenario es el
caso siguiente
imagínate que el banco central de tu
país le llega un dinero extra y lo que
va a querer hacer es prestar ese dinero
ojo en el vídeo pasado lo que vimos era
que pasaba si el banco o el gobierno
tenía más dinero y tanto el dinero que
podía regalar dinero y por lo tanto se
subían a un helicóptero y empezaban a
aventar lo desde los cielos pero bueno
realmente eso no pasa menos que imprima
dinero como lo que realmente lo que pasa
es que cuando el banco le dan más dinero
en entonces el banco no te va a regalar
el dinero lo que va a hacer es prestarte
más dinero pero realmente lo que quiere
el banco es ponerlo en un lugar seguro
muchas veces lo que hace es comprar este
seguro se acerca del gobierno algunos
títulos públicos o fondos del estado lo
que sea para que su dinero no tenga
tanto riesgo y cómo está nuestra curva
de oferta entonces ahora lo que va a
pasar es que el banco va a tener
y dinero que prestar y entonces qué va a
pasar
bueno al menos lo que sabemos es que la
curva de la oferta se va a mover hacia
la derecha es decir para cada uno de los
precios de las tasas de interés que yo
tengo aquí la oferta va a aumentar o
dicho de otra manera va a ver más
cantidad de dinero que van a poder
prestar y por lo tanto se va a ver algo
así y si asumimos que solamente este es
el único cambio que va a suceder por lo
tanto la curva de la demanda no se va a
mover se va a mantener idéntica y
entonces nuestro nuevo punto de
equilibrio si te das cuenta lo que hizo
fue disminuir en el precio es decir en
la tasa de interés es decir cuando un
banco dice que va a bajar sus tasas de
interés realmente lo que está pasando es
que ese banco tiene más dinero iba a
prestar ese dinero este es el primer
caso en el cual el banco va a imprimir y
prestar dinero y ojo estoy diciendo en
cierta manera que van a prestar el
dinero al gobierno es decir van a
comprar títulos públicos de respaldo y
va a haber próximos vídeos que voy a
hablar con más detalle de todo esto pero
vámonos al segundo escenario
segundo escenario va a ser cuando la
caja de ahorros del consumidor se va
hacia abajo y es que veamos los y los
ahorros y la inversión son dos caras de
la misma moneda
así que pensemos en el dinero es decir
en los ahorros y lo podemos poner
adentro de un banco este de aquí va a
ser el sistema financiero lo que
realmente está pasando es que tu dinero
lo van a sacar del banco y lo van a
prestar a alguna otra persona que lo
necesita pero para tu fortuna o para la
fortuna del banco lo que pasa es que el
dinero se lo van a prestar a alguna
gente que va a invertir con él entonces
aquí préstamo que tu caja de ahorros se
vaya hacia abajo lo que quiere decir es
que va a haber menos cantidad de dinero
es decir la oferta del dinero se va a ir
hacia abajo es decir para cada precio
tasa interés que tenemos aquí va a
existir menos cantidad de dinero que se
pueda prestar así que en este caso lo
que va a pasar es que nuestra curva de
la oferta se va a recorrer hacia la
derecha y esto lo que hace es que
aumente la tasa de interés del punto de
equilibrio y esto lo podemos pensar así
la caja de ahorros de los consumidores
se va hacia abajo y por lo tanto los
consumidores van a pedir prestado más
y eso quiere decir en otras palabras
también que la demanda va a irse hacia
arriba lo que va a hacer que el punto de
equilibrio que nosotros teníamos en un
principio se va a elevar bastante en la
tasa de interés ahora pasemos al tercer
escenario en este tercer escenario al
gobierno federal se le va a ocurrir o va
a necesitar pedir prestado más dinero no
sé por qué supongamos que lo que va a
necesitar es hacer algún programa de
interés público o no sé pero lo
importante va a ser que va a pedir
prestado más dinero esencialmente lo que
va a pasar es que el gobierno va a
aumentar su déficit por lo tanto como lo
escribimos el gobierno va a pedir
prestado dinero y bueno lo primero que
va a pasar es que la curva de la oferta
no va a cambiar porque el banco no va a
emitir ni va a ser más dinero y bueno
esto es bueno porque entonces tus
ahorros y tu caja de ahorros no va a
cambiar se va a mantener constante pero
la demanda es la que va a aumentar
porque ahora el gobierno también es el
que necesita dinero y como el gobierno
lo que necesita es dinero pues va a
pedir un préstamo al banco y entonces la
curva de la demanda se va a recorrer
hacia la derecha y si te das cuenta
ahora en nuestro nuevo punto de
equilibrio
entonces el precio y la tasa de interés
o en su dado caso la renta del dinero va
a aumentar y bueno lo importante de todo
este vídeo es que yo quiero que veas que
el dinero no es ni más ni menos que otro
servicio por lo tanto las gráficas se
ven muy parecidas si la oferta aumenta
entonces el precio o la tasa de interés
se iba hacia abajo después vimos que si
la demanda era la que aumentaba entonces
la tasa de interés tasa de interés
también aumentaba y bueno también puedes
pensar en todas las demás combinaciones
si la demanda se va hacia abajo entonces
la tasa interés se va hacia abajo si la
oferta se va hacia abajo entonces la
tasa interés aumenta pero al final lo
que te quería enseñar de todo esto es
que no es tan difícil seguramente tarde
o temprano vas a escuchar que el
gobierno está necesitando más dinero o
que la caja de ahorros off hacia abajo o
lo que sea por el final no estamos
hablando ni más ni menos que las dos
curvas la de la demanda como la de la
oferta del dinero y también no está de
más nunca olvidar que entonces la tasa
de interés es la renta sobre el dinero